[Musique]
je trouve que sur les retraites c'est
quand même le grand flou artistique du
gouvernement la question c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe réellement derrière les
effets d'annoncé
moi je vais suivre avec intérêt par
exemple la réforme des retraites ou bien
la réforme effectivement de la fonction
publique regardant réellement ce qui va
se passer on est devant des sujets qui
engagent notre avenir
il faut décider on peut pas non plus
sans arrêt ne jamais décidé françois
hollande avait pas décidé grand chose
ils auraient dû le faire c'était prévu
en 2010 il était prévu de d'engager un
nouveau cycle de décision à partir de
il l'a pas fait emmanuel macron décide
de le faire tant mieux il a raison mais
à un moment donné il faut arrêter de
deux concerts maintenant il faut aussi
décidé il faut avancer et on ne peut pas
jouer avec les nerfs des français sur un
sujet aussi complexe est aussi
fondamental que celui de leur retraite
leur retraite c'est le travail de toute
leur vie c'est leur avenir c'est
l'avenir de leurs enfants
il est absolument fondamental qu enfin
le gouvernement nous dise quel est son
cap et quelle est sa vision et qu'on
puisse enfin avoir l'esprit clair sur un
sujet comme celui ci qu'on ne peut pas
dire en même temps il ya un problème et
en même temps je ne le traite pas et en
même temps on a notre produit intérieur
brut 100% de la dette parce que c'est
quand même ça le fond du sujet on a
toujours un chômage de masse qui est
important à 6 millions de chômeurs on a
neuf millions de pots et on a une dette
qui a 100% du pib
donc si on nie pas les choses comme ça
aux français comment fait homme
qu'attendent les gens de droite ne sont
pas faites aujourd'hui lorsque emmanuel
macron s'engageait sur la baisse des
dépenses publiques la réalité c'est
qu'ils augmentent les dépenses publiques
beaucoup plus vite que ne le faisait
françois hollande lorsqu'il il appelait
au désendettement de la france avec une
croissance qui repart la réalité c'est
que par rapport à françois hollande il
augmentait la dette
il est très évident que l'équilibré de
nos comptes publics est une garantie
indispensable pour préparer notre avenir
[Musique]